okay I will call all members in
alphabetical order
counselor passenger yes hello burn I'm
here
Thank You counselor it can stabile no
counselor bell here counselor boys
yeah counselor chana hello chairman and
hello burner yes I'm here thank you cast
off Luka you're a pleasant burner that
the link isn't working from the modern
District Council website if you click on
it where it says southeast Planning
Committee livestream it's not working
it's going to let right know that it
says video unavailable I think you know
counselor Thompson has managed to pick
out from somewhere but if you go on to
the MDC website go to South East area
planning committee 10th of June and
click on the link it's it's it's not
working I got them sorry it's not
available what's on youtube so i hit the
what's on YouTube and then I get it but
I've only got the earlier part I've got
a message come up on my screen saying a
recording has started this meeting is
being recorded by joining you are giving
consent for this meeting to be recorded
privacy policy which recording is that
cuz I haven't seen it on our other
council meetings is that a separate
recording going on elsewhere no no this
is the same recording the YouTube
recording so that policy first time I've
seen it when we've used YouTube if
that's where it's coming from
I think that's some counselor Thompson
said she had clicked recording I think
that thing at the top is in relation to
teams only I don't know if anyone is
still recording or not but I think it
relates to that rather than well if it
makes everyone happy but if someone
tells me how I'm supposed to stop the
recording is easy enough to start it but
I know how to stop it information and
I'll do that
can sit anywhere in any meeting and yes
I don't think it makes any difference at
your recording it says cancel Erskine's
thank you my screen saying that the
meeting being recorded by joining you
are giving consent for this meeting to
be recorded that seems it has to be a
holistic consent for the committee that
we're just checking the link from the
web one more time chairman can I just
say the message I've got is the empty
the link where this person's looking in
from the MDC meeting notice link like
last week so they are getting it from
the MDC link yes that is correct
you
okay chairman we're back live and do you
want to you want to go oh no I'll just
we just start with the roll call okay
members I will take you in alphabetical
order
counselor passenger Reuters its appeal
no cast a bell still prison Oh counselor
boys castle boys Castle Janet hello
I'm still present have been waiting yeah
kids Casa Luker
basin Kassar helm yes present caster
hull counselor hull counselor Skeens
yes I'm prison counselor stamp
yes thank you burner Thank You counsel
Thank You boys thank you okay chairman
thank you
we're ready for speed neroli yes
gracious of interest declarations of
interest please councillor Morrison
attended blonde light thank you okay I
have a declaration to well to actually
to make don't you continue chairman I
have a non-pecuniary interesting that
I'm also a member of Essex County
Council and they're consulted on
applications in terms of matters of
highways and anything in their remit
that they should be consulted on with
the application and also I declare and
I've now got really able to see the
papers on another screen a small screen
it's agenda item number six it's
actually the second application we're
considering I must declare non-pecuniary
I also know the applicant anymore cast
Erskine's I believe crash Town Council
and therefore have a non pecuniary
interest in all these matters right I
have chairman please I know the
applicants on agenda item six and its
council assistant Thank You councillor
stab anybody else chairman I did did
actually put two comments on chap that I
wanted to declare an interest because I
thought that's what we were supposed to
do so a chairman in relation to agenda
item five Station Road Burnham on Crouch
I own the adjacent property so I shall
declare a pecuniary interest and take no
part in that item and leave the meeting
and chairman in relation to item number
six I know the applicant and I think
chairman in light of the situation
between the Secretary of State Robert
Genrich and the DCA Choji and in
particular his dealings with Richard
Desmond's
with the development of West very works
on the Isle of Dogs and the overall
significance of that I'm going to
declare a pecuniary interest in relation
with my association with the applicants
so I should take no part in that
discussion chairman and I will leave the
meeting now I think because unless there
are any other items of business Chairman
it you're gonna say chairman I'll leave
the meeting now and I was actually going
to pay tribute to everybody for this
very historical moment when we managed
to get the southeast area planning
committee done virtually and completely
seamlessly but where I am today chairman
the incumbent
it's his birthday today and I've been
invited to the lower house to have a tea
and biscuits so good luck to you all and
have a lovely afternoon
tiddly thank you chairman would that be
minute it because it's hardly relevant
is it well it's I've gone on the
recording so unless you might take it
off well no but I mean come on it's a
planning meeting we don't need to know
somebody what they're doing after the
meet and surely chairman may I please
just inquire something councilor
feluccas declaration he's leaving the
meeting because of what he's doing it's
not because of his relationship with the
applicant on the second application
thank you what do you mean well I
thought he declared a beauty interest in
both cases yeah I don't quite understand
the opportunity with the applicant the
second application do I have to do the
same because I know the applicant
through a certain Association that I'm a
member of he decided to declare a
peculiar interest it's up to each member
to declare how they feel fit at the time
are we satisfied now well in that case
you can't sort of Luke on the second one
declare bikini because the relationship
is not aptly kept then perhaps I will I
mean I know the lady purely through an
association of which I'm a member of my
party actually
so perhaps then in that case I'll get
out application number two okay hang on
hang on
cancer journey that means that the
majority of the conservative politics I
think that's what you're alluding to
will not take part in this meeting can
we have some some clarity German it's
not an argument just seeking
clarification and what I'm counselor
felucca said because I read to read to
do with the Association and therefore if
that's the case then I will get out I've
just wanted clarity on his wording can
anyone assist Lee
the wording really is don't cancel ooh
can use the chairman chairman and also
counselor channa
I think it's George if you feel it's a
pecuniary interest then obviously you
must make your decision yes if you don't
feel it is well stay in III mean I can't
can't that's just my feeling huh just
because all I'm saying just because the
Kuna interests are not little arguments
I'm just saying
my understanding is number Curie I know
the applicant but in light of what I
wanted if the minute takers got the
exact wording which I hope is the case I
just wanted to hear what counsel a
felucca said again because if this now
comes into the equation then I'm going
to leave the meeting for that
application
because it's an association I have
through my party okay
apologies I I can't just at the moment
because I was just in the middle of
trying to set up the other chat line for
members and I will be able to check with
the recording bus and I if you just bear
with me for a second please
can I suggest that we proceed with the
meeting and then stop at the point of
the second we'll move on now
so agenda item 5 pen application 2171 to
173 Station Road Burnham on Crouch SEMO
8j
why found on pages 11 to 13 please note
there's also a members updates this
application has been pulled in by
counsel at Bo and is the moment
recommended for refusal can I now ask
the officer to present the meeting other
plans please thank you to the clinic
planning permission is sought for the
partial change of use of the
and first floor from a shop to
residential accommodation the proposed
development would involve the demolition
for the demolition of an outbuilding to
the south of the main building at the
erection of a single-story room
extension and the installation of new
fan of a new vents and gates here we
have the location plan and the block
plan where you can see the rear
extension the existing ground floor
plans OS ground floor plans so you can
see these areas have been converted to
residential the existing first floor
plan and the proposed first floor plan
and this areas been converted to
residential and we've got the existing
rear and internal side elevations and
the proposed rear and internal side
elevations got the existing front and
side elevation as visible from the
street scene and the proposed elevations
then we've got the site photos post
development is identical to a previously
refused scheme the additional
information contained within the design
and access statement is not considered
to overcome the previous reason for
refusal the proposal would result in the
partial loss of an existing read how
unit which is likely to result in the
unit being unable to suitably function
for its purpose the proposal also
results in the unjustified loss of
employment land whilst the lawful use of
the outbuildings to the rear of the main
building has been questioned to previous
applications confirm that the buildings
were redundant boatbuilding and repair
sheds which were most recently used for
repairing lawnmowers this was accepted
by the council and the applications were
determined on this basis there's been no
evidence or information some supply
which disproves this therefore the
proposal is recommended for refusal on
the basis of the loss of employment land
and partial loss of the retail unit so
chair thank you Miss bolts we have two
submission submission number one from
Nick Hutton Penman a supporter I'm very
supportive of this planning application
that it is taking an historic building
and burning on Crouch and restoring it
to its former glory at the same time
improving and maintaining a small
business in the town's main high street
the building has agreed planning to
convert the properties into flats which
lapse because of the building and it's
outbuildings could not be sold
the current owners are long-standing
Burnham family who have a history of
shop keeping in the town purchased the
property to use as their family home as
well as run a small business
the current planning application
includes plans to transform the building
into an upgraded family home whilst
maintaining many of the original
building features the removal of an
unsightly tin shed that was a late
addition and is in complete disrepair to
provide badly needed off street parking
and maintain the business element it is
difficult to understand how such an
application could be considered in any
way other than possibly by the planning
authority it significantly improves the
aspect of the town and the business that
will be run from it and will attract
people to the high street
therefore benefiting all small
businesses the planning application
includes a request to reduce the size of
the commercial footprint back to
original footprint size which serves two
purposes firstly it scours the business
premises to a footprint commiserate with
the requirements and budgetary costs of
a business that will fill it and give it
some chance of a success rather than
burdening it with unnecessary costs
secondly it returns the family property
back to its original size the previous
owner having extended the business
element the shop and outbuildings do not
and never have had any running water
fresh
the rear brick shed is also in disrepair
but is to be kept and renovated there
for the historical purpose of the
building as an arm mangas would remain
or any tourist interested in a local
history overall this application can
only benefit the town the improves
historic building in the town removes
and another slightly shed and promote
small businesses in the town I would
urge you support this planning
application alright there's another
submission submission tooth and he'll
endorsing the applicant to address the
main reason for fusil which are related
to the rear shapes and their historical
purpose and researched and spoken to
many people who through generations have
never known the two sheds to be used for
boat boarding or repairs it was an arm
mungus mongers research uncover two
story buildings that was a hard standing
behind a brick building once used for
marine engineering k JY t then car
repairs owned by mr. baker subsequently
burnt down and was never part of any of
our buildings or plot we have
photographic evidence of this two-story
building we own a large box of ledges
found in the property dating back to
1912 and not one mentions of both
building repairs or River related trades
in any of these ledges there is much
historical evidence of the local museum
relating to the hardware store and our
memories but again no mention of boat
building application 1905 six old stated
that the workshops are beyond economic
repair no amount of sales marketing
would be successful therefore no loss to
employment land as it cannot be used for
business there appears to be no solid
proof in this application so the
workshops is start used we brought this
property to live live and work in the
town and then
local support the shop is currently set
up for trading and it works incredibly
well in these very uncertain times we
are still trying striving and working
hard to run our business and to provide
service to the town as well as live love
and renovate a beautiful building on the
last few remaining old Burnham on Crouch
chairmen may refer to other offices
before finally moving to the
recommendation any other offices want to
make a comment the recommendation is set
out with her in the port is as follows
the planning application 220 stroke
double-o 11 3 ful for 171 172 Road
Burnham on Crouch be refused the reasons
detailed the report below if any majors
member wishes the second is the motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
thank you all for it members to make
comments on the report yes please mr.
chairman yes yes Thank You mr. chairman
um first of all can I say I'm
flabbergasted with the amount of
evidence that the applicant has provided
that this premises was never used for
River related trades flabbergasted the
officers are still refuting this um
secondly I'd like to acknowledge yes
this is a difficult site it's a heritage
assets it's in the conservation area it
is one of the biggest retail spaces we
have but also it is in a flood zone it
has no eradicated shop pearl King and
I'm amazed again that officers have
absolutely given no reference made no
reference to the impact that kovat 19 is
clearly having and will have for a
significant amount of time on our high
streets in terms of retail and retail
space so um first of all the reduction
still
this is one of the biggest shops in
Birnam it makes it more sustainable it
returns it to the original footprint the
officer spoke that actually said several
times that it had been converted to
residential the ground floor space it
was previously
it was previously residential and it was
previously sorry retail so actually the
current position is not so is not the
original one I think under the
circumstance is the conservation officer
agrees he supports this sorry bear with
me bear with me and the planning listed
building and conservation areas Act of
1990 does require that council pay
special attention to the desirability of
preserving and enhancing the character
and appearance of the conservation area
and I advise that this proposed
application would indeed do that for as
a preserve and enhance of the character
so there's been no previous previous
objection from from sorry there with me
from EA yes sorry that was slightly
garbled but some been waiting a long
time to say that but I really I really
cannot see how there can be any
objection to this application it does
everything we need it to do for Burnham
and I would propose that we are support
this application thank you I'll sector e
Angeles stamp will second that mitigates
we go to the vote Thank You chairman and
obviously councillor Bell raised a
number of points in her comment um two
seconds just trying to something
right oops obviously councillor Bell
made reference to the level of evidence
provided my understanding an officer
highlighted and I'm sure she can correct
me if I'm wrong I think we've had four
pictures and a statement about Ledger's
and a statement about Ledger's is to
argue that the site has not been used
for employment based uses in relation to
the maritime obviously that person I
think that's quite a small amount of
information that's been submitted as
part of the application especially when
you think the previous submissions from
the applicant have stated the opposite
and so obviously that is sent we need to
balance and I don't think that either
said for photos and a statement about
Ledger's is really a lot for the council
to base a decision on notwithstanding
this it was comment about having no
on-site car parking obviously this is a
high street location or retail area in
most instances such as this that is
relatively common but the car parking
section is actually within the officers
repo and obviously deals with that
because obviously the expansion of the
residential accommodation obviously has
an offset so that's a bit of a moot
point personally and I said I would be
worried if officers or members
considered lots of retail because they
don't have allocated sites is a
principle of supporting such proposals
because that would then drill into the
heart of any application to lose a
retail unit in pretty much every high
street across the district the property
has he's partially converted this bill
said it's not the original but that
shouldn't be a consideration of much
weight because we are dealing with a
planning application at this time as is
and as members now each application must
be turned on its own merits and on the
basis of what's in front of us obviously
this is an old property this has had a
long history of life even you know
before the planning system so things are
going to change but we have to determine
applique
today in 2020 with what the site is as
it is a note the comments about the
conservation area and conservation
officers comments but neither of the
reasons we refuse will relate to that
point it you know as members aware an
application needs to be considered
against all the various policy
requirements that relate to the
application the impact on the
conservation area is just one of those
and that is dealt with in the officers
report and explains that bubsley
that isn't reason fuser on either of the
other two reasons of refusal and just in
relation to co vid 19 I think as an
authority institution might we need to
be very conscious of this we don't know
exactly how the impacts are going to be
and we shouldn't be making assumptions
and our policies don't allow for that
and on the other side as we all know we
need to turn applications in relation to
their life at the development there is
large be impact and Coby night I'm not
saying there won't be but this one's
this is granted it's likely we will lose
the retail unit or the the aspect of it
permanently and I don't think members
really should be giving a lot of weight
to the current situation created by
coping 19 termination of application
when looking against what government
guidance is in case lawyers and just
determining planning applications thank
you cheering we've got councillor Bell
and councillors gauge wish to speak in
please as their birthdays Cass LaBelle
can you switch your microphone on your
video on please that's labelled
story I'm losing internet counts the
belt I'm losing Internet here we can
hear you
so I take counsel skis first thing
cancer skates yes
two things I remember this site from my
childhood now obviously as you can see
from the photographs there was maritime
use of further down in in the yard which
belongs to priors I do not recall from
from the age of twelve onwards back in
the 70s the shop itself having anything
to do with maritime there was a
possibility of buying hardware that you
could use on the boat but you always
prefer to go to the Chandler's which
were more expensive but had gear better
suited to the maritime world so I don't
think I don't I don't recall it back
from the 70s and it was used I'm
assuming of course that the boat yard
further down where the boats are parked
in the pictures has nothing to do with
this the only question I really have is
the gating and from what I can see in
the application it seems pretty clear
the gating is in between the two
buildings the brick building and the
main building with the cast out the
corrugated iron building being knocked
down in between I just want to be sure
that there's no other gating blocking
access from the High Street through to
the key because there is a route round
there that's been used for time out of
mind
and I wouldn't want to see that blocked
I was just wondering if an officer can
confirm there's no proposals that they
have seen I haven't seen them I must say
to block off their access through to the
key round the back of Pryor's malting
sheds can off sources please regarding
the gating
Hannah you have to pick the helpers case
up some Yap through you chair I don't
believe the accesses cuts off it's just
sectioning off the part where the the
tin shed is going to be demolished Thank
You chair yes Thank You mr. chairman
sorry I lost internet for a moment there
um just to come back I wonder if mr. Lee
might like to look at the pay a visit to
burn a museum where he will find ledgers
dating back and other information
photographs etc supporting the
applicants assertion that this is not
some related to River trades I just I
just want to repeat this is a I believe
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
that we have where somebody who loves
Burnham who loves this particular shop
wants to make a go of it in what is a
very very very difficult challenging
retail climate and I applaud that and I
really think this is the type of
initiative that we should be supporting
Thank You mr. chairman mr. Bell cast the
stone please yes thank you chairman um
it's
obviously I've left it to the to ward
members but there is something I did on
message members to look at and what's
the only mention of the previous history
on this site for planning that was spent
because I can't remember exactly if
twelve flats or six flats was approved
on this site but they taught the length
of time expired so that application
planning approval fell flat now if you
consider that they were going to change
the whole of it and lose the whole of it
is a retail site two flats and now we're
querying a person who wants to keep part
of it and extend it into live
accommodation to to accommodate one
family I find absolutely astonishing and
I know mr. Lee will come back with me
and he's normal every application has to
be viewed on its own merit etc Kansas
stamp and I'm not being funny cancel it
mr. leagues I know that you'll say that
to me but we have to not
this in relation to our high street it
is a small business she just want to or
they do want to make a go of it they're
not changing anything massively they're
going to try and tidy up that site it is
a mess down there members and to be
quite honest I was really unsure that
the first time this came to burn in Town
Council and I think actually I was going
to refuse it but the more I've looked
into it I actually do support this
application and I think we should be
applauding like cats have barely said in
this economic climate I take on board
what mr. Lee says we can't overreact or
whatever if co big 19 but I like this I
think this is going to be nice for the
town I think it's going to attract open
another retail space which has closed
down the t's closed down members I don't
know if you've all been to visit members
but it is closed at the moment it's a
vacant shop
we've got other shops and now being
brought back to life and I think the
care and attention the applicant is made
here will enhance our high streets and I
really do
urge members to you've got any questions
please ask
obviously the offices but supporters
this is what well I certainly would like
and so would cancel it Bell Thank You
chairman that's it Thank You chairman
obviously points raised by Chancellor
bonus objective of say just comment on
what I'd said no real points like that
other than obviously isn't the council's
issue to go to museums and obviously it
should be submitted with the application
to support the application and that is
the responsibility of the applicant and
that is how the planning system works in
relation to councillors stamps point I'm
sure if members I'm sure can stamp knows
and not to all the other members do that
previous application and the weight to
be attributed to that is assessed in
paragraph three point one point ten if
the officers were poll and while I do
know what the application was for is has
expired and also that was considered
prior to the adoption of the current LDP
and actually if off the cuff I think
before we had a five-year land supply so
obviously that is a very different
set of planning landscapes that we found
ourself in at that time - what we do now
and just to prove cancer stamp right
each application must be determined on
its own merit Thank You chairman thank
you very much that was not seconded so
we have a recommendation for our
counselor Bell for approval seconded by
Councillor stamp can I have some reasons
please can we have recorded votes as
well please yeah you may have recorded
vote yes mr. chairman um principle of
sustainable development under the NPP F
plays as a reason anymore I can't think
of any more I think it's just it will
actually and no it's not planning reason
but it will contribute enhance to own
our retail site chairman mr. Lewis sorry
mr. chairman also the Heritage one the
English Heritage one that I stated
earlier bear with me a moment I'll get
my notes carry on Thank You chairman
I'll be honest I've got concerns in
relation to the point that councillor
Bell just raised
not if the region's refused will go
against or relate to the conservation
area obviously Office report does
discuss the need to preserve or enhance
the character of a conservation area and
arguing or putting forward the position
that the council considers just because
the development is except in a
conservation area pearance that it
conflicts with other policies and that
should be thrown out with the bath baby
should be found out with a bath fault we
should undermine those policies is a
worry I would say members because it
that isn't the reason for use with
members if it was up for a refused one
impact on the conservation even actually
members thought it preserved it or
enhanced it that would be different but
the need to preserve enhance the
conservation is very different to what
the two reasons we refused to are
obvious members think that there isn't a
lot of employment from maritime because
they consider that
enough evidence has been provided or in
their opinion isn't an issue that's one
thing same as the impact on the retail
is one thing but I would be very worried
and concerned about using the fact that
it just preserves enhance of the
conservation here is a reason to ignore
the two other policy reasons for refusal
Thank You chairman if I say something
this I mean well I think this is a
question of history it strikes the
burner members clearly as an effort to
preserve the history far more than the
previous application that I realizes is
on its own merits but on its own merits
is better than the last one there is
some effort to preserve their history
the historical feel of the place and I
think that is the sort of reason why
councillors get to make decisions like
this against the Planning Officers
recommendations because they live there
and they know the history and I would
say that as I said I said before my
memory of it that it was not that just
this particular exact site with the red
line round it was not used for for
maritime employment and it is awful
offering the chance of more employment
at least in the shop so I think those
are reasons mr. lay members gift seen
members gift
obviously they reason fish Thank You
chairman mr. Lee said and he was very
helpful when he was that he was
highlighting the reasons for refusal so
can we not just go on the opposite we
don't feel it's an unjustified loss of
employment because it's still providing
employment so that's the first thing and
it still when it says contributes to the
tourist attraction why would it not
contribute to the tourist attraction so
I think merely for the reasons the
refusal for section 1 we just go for the
opposite reasons chairman mr. he might
be really kind and help me out on that
all right agree counts the stamp grave
agree with you there
yeah as I said earlier if members
consider that you know evidence has been
provided it shows that they lost
it's not maritime employment isn't an
issue and that in their opinion that the
retail unit would still be a viable
option that would be you know planning
based reason for approval I think that
would be appropriate without actually
looking at undermining any other
position thank chairman mr. Lee in the
condition if it is improved make sure
that the repect remaining retail space
is kept as a remaining retail space
chairman members in relation to this
application it's quite a complex
application so rather than listing
conditions which I normally would do I
would recommend that this would be
delegated to officers through
consultation with the chairman in
relation to any conditions in relation
to specifically the point of the retail
area we would normally condition
something along those lines
the exact wording probably wouldn't be
as draconian as maybe council stamps
thinking because that would need
planning permission and the government
guidance and case law was clear that at
the planning condition has to meet the
six tests and one of them is necessary
so we would require it to be remain as a
retail unit but that wouldn't stop the
potential for a plan application future
or anything like that
Thank You chairman I'm happy with that
we haven't had a vote yet but we now
take a vote please she's muted you're
muted burner you're muted yeah I know
I'm trying to unmute myself but can you
now focus the key sir sorry Khepri
muting me and
yes a people country to the officers
recommendation okay thank you very much
so counselor Basinger has the passenger
well I would like to approve the
application Thank You councillor Bell
for voice it's still present cancerboys
okay counselor chana abstain counselor
Fluker sorry who's left
casteau ham abstain as a hull castle
hull has their hollow you stir that okay
cast Erskine's for approval cancellous
can stir stamp burner please okay so
that's for by the castle help ruse okay
so that's five for the wreck for
approval none against two abstentions
okay that is duly approved
I've got four for approval can we just
have the people who have approved it so
we don't make a mistake
I had the first passenger cancel a bell
councillor hull yeah councillor Skeens
councillors stamp Thank You burner I
pour approval thank you thank you very
much for that members we move on to item
six
late work here will be well away we'll
get there in a minute
chairman just coming in on this one oh
yes counselor through kazan declaration
procuring it appears from what burn is
written I'm sorry I'm perhaps I'm being
thick I don't quite recognize what the
association is with the Secretary of
State and the DC LG development and I
can't assist you with that it's up to
you to decide whether you've got keener
interest or not I understand that
chairman but I'm asking as a
conservative because is it linked to
that it seems to me the the Secretary of
State was a found of bias to do with
something to help a developer save money
and I'm not sure I understand what
implication that has got with this
application I know the applicant only
purely because I'm I'm a conservative
and they're in the same conservative
party as me but I have certainly had no
dealings or anything to do with any talk
with the applicant about this
application or anything so I'm I'm I'm
just propelled why Pecunia
it seem to infer to me that she'd all
conservatives but that would be a
nonsense because then you'd be talking
the same for liberal and Liberal
Democrats everywhere I suggest you do a
non-pecuniary interesting look at that
that's initially as well and counsel how
I think I would did you decide guess the
chat is not quite sure whether she had a
peculiar interest or no chairman
chairman I was quite clear at the start
of the meeting I declared non-pecuniary
it was in life invited helps my blue car
then bring him forward and going on
out the Secretary of State and the DC LG
Development so I had the screen off it
was in light of council of Lucca drawing
some similarities with the Secretary of
State in the DCO development at West
very works and the significance he
declared you ninjas now the significant
serve walls that's got to be
redetermination in Kling available for
the Secretary of State was found to be
influencing it because to save the
developer money and I certainly haven't
been involved in anything of like that
with this applicant so I think mines
still non-pecuniary I may not vote and
I'm gonna take it up with Simon cottage
because I really don't know what the de
CLG where spray to do with it right okay
cast the hull do you want to cede or not
hear me yes yes I just think it's a
number canary interest okay number 2000
2001 stroke house seven reside rhodomont
crouch the mo 8 j y garage conversion
with bow window and detect single
problem it's a members paul in but
that's the window step and the
recommendation is refusal right would
officers like to make a presentation
please thank you tear and if you want to
speak can you use the chat function
please thank you thank so planning
permission is sought for a garage
conversion with the insertion of a bow
window and the erection of a detached
single cartridge here we've got the
vocation plan and the block plan or you
can see the proposed cart lodge to the
front here and the garage to be
converted here we've got the existing
ground floor plans
and the proposed ground floor plans
using elevation plan and the proposed
elevation plans and the proposed car
Lord elevations
we've got from fight photos the proposed
cart Lodge is located in a prominent
position to the front of the dwelling
and is not a development commonly found
within the existing street scene it's
considered to form a dominant and
incongruous addition harm in the visual
amenity and the site and surrounding
Conservation Area in addition the
proposal would lead to a shortfall of
off-street car parking spaces therefore
the proposal is recommended for refusal
thank you chair thank you very much I'll
have two submissions here
welcome Council Ron Pat on behalf of the
town council this application is similar
and many others in Berlin where the
garage is converted into living or
office accommodation the added bonus in
this application is that there is
adequate space in the front garden for
two cars the existing garage I believe
is too narrow for modern cars the cart
Lodge will give protection from these
set droppings from the preserved tree
the cart log uses garden space and adds
to the off street parking the Bern town
council sees no reason not to approve
the necessary improvements to mrs. Owens
residence
she needs a separate shower this gives
OV X submission to the main bedroom of
seven Riverside Road needs a shower
facility next to the present lavatory
and wash basin utility area is a
makeshift affair which needs to be
updated refurbished and complete it to
an acceptable standard the garage space
is filled with household paraphernalia
since it is difficult to get out of the
car once it is parked inside you make a
pretty bedroom and in arts the value of
the band blow when I die for the benefit
of my three children lived modestly and
have families to support and have
families to support another bedroom
would be better use of the space and
provide a comfortable well furnished
home for family there are a variety of
windows which create interest in the
road and Oriel window was discussed but
rejected because it might just out -
just out too much the choice was made
for a bow window to harmonize with that
of the number-10 a the bungalow named
heritage almost opposite mine by car
needs some sort of protection pictures
and of colored of doves a black Berman
Robin all roost in the simple maple free
and deposit their droppings as in see
girls starlings Erin when flying
overhead there is a constant fall of sap
from the leaves which leaves a sticky
substance on the car from spring to
autumn
the car is very hot in the summer and
frosty in the winter and my energy
levels are decreasing so it's difficult
to keep the car clean and presentable
every time I go out I'm 86 the maple
tree was planted by me several years ago
I'm I am its friend it was my neighbor
who disliked the tree and one bit failed
I put an application order to please her
which resulted in the preservation order
the wet posts of the carport would be
continued
continuous of the building line of the
recent build terrace at the townhouse is
called tide ways the east post would be
outside the area given to the tree
president tree to protect it I
respectfully request that members of the
counts put forward a motion to approve
my planning application officers would
you like to come in there moment
chairman obviously that's that becomes
position I'll see what I would say is
I'm just conscious that a lot of the
issues that raised not in my
professional opinion be classes very
special circumstances it be
circumstances that most individuals
would feel and
should be given appropriate way in the
determination thank you right the
recommendation is to be refused the
founding member wishes the second that
motion please turn on your video unmute
your microphone and state your name now
nobody won the second that thank you are
now invite members to make any comments
on the report it was indicated anyone
indicated chairman I'll speak after the
two board members if you like I no no I
called it in but it's only protocol if
the two board members this is a
conservation area this is some you know
this is this is a bungalow in a in an
ordinary Street there's no particular
issue with visuals as far as I can see
this seems to me there's a channel we
often find ourselves approving annexes
and other kind of ways that people can
remain in in their accommodation and to
me this appears to be nothing more than
that
you know the applicant wants shower room
that she can use I really can't see
anything wrong with this application mr.
Sherman's so I would actually move that
we support it if there's a seconder for
that I'll second that chairman cancer
stamp who else wants to speak please
I'll speak chairman of cancer schemes I
don't if cancer schemes are still here
I'm still here but I'm loving to add to
up them to what we're really being said
by counsel about okay that's the stamp
place okay oh gosh sorry I forgot to put
my video what it's better for you we
don't have it anyway chairman and so
much better picture than the icon anyway
excuse me sorry chairman and I'm a
little bit of standard you know we're
refusing something cuz small is this
to somebody who you know it's going to
make her living conditions easier and
it's within our development boundaries
but yet we can approve something on
previous applications that's a monster
outside the development boundary
I know mr. Lee don't I won't say it
members are going to tell me off here
each application on its own right you
have to take things as a whole in a town
and you have to represent your
constituents accordingly I personally
have driven past this place I've looked
at it I take on board all the comments
and I think the actual email from the
owner
okay the rigid planning reasons in there
but that just shows you how her life is
being impacted and how much she cares
where she lives so I don't believe that
her application is going to change and
cause any detrimental harm to where she
actually lives
that's the Pratt says exactly the same I
totally agree with what kind of
counselor Pratt said so I would actually
like to say I don't agree with the
officers recommendation and a cart large
is classed as a non-permanent structure
for the reasons that it is non permanent
and I don't I agree she needs to put her
car away and if you look at the plan in
history chairman you can see how
conscientious and this applicant has
been and always going for proper
planning permissions trees everything
you know and I know it's not an issue
mr. Lee here but it just shows how
conscientious and how they want to do
everything correct no I think she should
be commended on that I did not agree
with their offices recommendation I
don't think it is detrimental to the
character I don't think it is in the
contrary to policies d1 d3 and H file
and I agree with counselor Bell and I
don't agree don't I think it is a
problem with t2 and I agree with counsel
avail that we should approve this
application Thank You chairman obviously
you know as members know each
application as a merit and but I think
there's a couple of points I'd like to
raise
there is a a big difference obviously
between a household of extinction and
you know strategic site or an allocated
so an industrial site and each
application has its own material
considerations it has own policy process
to go through and I don't think as an
authority we should be looking at a
thought process which is what was
implied in my opinion that anything that
you've seen is basic household extension
it should be approved on the assumption
that it is not as harmful as another
scheme we need to look at each
application its own Mary and I think
that is important and I'm not saying
members aren't doing that but just
obviously you need to reiterate that
from what could be inferred from volumes
of public in planning terms are quite
large cart Lodge so he's a permanent
structure requires plan admission and
would be there for a foreseeable time
but I would warn members against giving
too much weight as I said to the need
for personal circumstances because they
are pretty much general personal so in
case law is clear that it needs to be
very special circumstances and just
because someone is getting old or
there's a personal issue or something
that should not be per se a reason to
support an application and the weight
should reflect whether it's very special
circumstances and I'd also advise
members to the fact that applications
have previously been submitted not to
weigh in favor of the application ID
because that would then mean if someone
hadn't submitted a previous application
we'd be inferring that we would not be
supporting them on that point so I think
for those two issues as I said this two
reasons for futile for this application
so not to isn't it sorry just sorry come
back said there's two reasons for a few
so one relates to the car scale and
positioning and design which was said
it's a subjective matter which hasn't
really been talked about rather than
saying that there's an age of the car
Pavan as I said I'll worry about giving
that too much weigh in its overall
process
as I said there's no particular special
certain answers and if we replicated
that across the district you know that
would be a problem and the other issue
is about the creating bedrooms result in
a detrimental impact on this area due to
highway safety due to not meeting the
car parking requirements and neither of
those points have really been talked at
so at the moment I'm not clear when if
members were to look to recommend
approval what the reasons for approval
would be based on the fact that no they
haven't talked the RIC this comment
reasons for refusal thank you chairman
thank you we have a proposal for going
against the officers recommendation
proposed by councilor Bell and seconded
by Councillor stamp
I now need valid reasons planning
reasons for approval please I think I
think I said them I don't agree with the
officers report I don't think it is
detrimental to policy d1 d3 in h4 and
councilor and mr. lee said obviously
some of it is subjective yes it is
subjective and and because of that
reason we don't or I certainly don't
think it will cause any harm in the
location it is and I thank mr. Lee for
corrected as he always does and we
always seem to do this with each other
and I wasn't implying anything of the
sort about decisions not being you know
outside and inside and we should approve
them inside the boundary or whatever and
now I don't agree with him so my might
and hopefully my other members the world
members will be able to support me on
this and I don't agree that it's against
the policies that they've said I think I
think we can support it
it isn't detrimental to the conservation
area it's not a huge great big thing and
I apologize I didn't think colleges were
permanent plan is structures only unless
they put doors in them because that's
what I was told but I apologize to mr.
Lee he he is the person in the know here
not me and I don't think it just create
any harm so that's that's the only thing
I don't and I would ask mr. Lee if he
can come back and
she say that's right all right can you
come back please always happy to help
members as a sitting recipe I'm I wanted
Clow wasn't saying it can't stand any
other member was saying that but what I
just obviously need to do is to make
sure there could be no influenced by
anybody that try to smooth over any
wrinkles that could be seen it as I said
yeah cartilage is steel development is
to a permanent structure it's not on we
already think so it is what it is to us
certainly since I am planning terms it
is a structure obviously they can stamps
talkin to the first reason fuse when as
I said earlier is subjective you know
its opinion on whether or not there is
harm on the character the area oil says
that there is still no comment on the
second reason for fusil in any of the
debate and obviously bias games should
be allowed either needs to be overall
that benefits without way harm which
talks across reasons refusal or it
should deal with each reason for refusal
because otherwise you know just for
sample there's five reasons for a few
officers recommended it wouldn't listen
mean that members agreed with all of
them but a scheme this is totally this
principle but a skin could still be
refused on three reasons for example
cetera so at the moment while understand
can't stem cancer stamps always putting
forward her position on the character
the area that you're saying there was
Neil still nothing in relation to
Highway Safety thank you chairman if I
could come back on that mr. chairman I
mean reading the officer reports about
you know well it's not viable as a
parking solution because cars would have
to reverse out reverse back in I'd say
that's pretty subjective because I'd say
if that might be an inconvenience for
the residents but I that doesn't make it
viable and I disagree that the impact on
highway safety is an issue so that's
that's my position on that thank you yes
like to say could I add to that yes
just to say that I agree I don't I think
the effective carport that is being
built for this car Lodge doesn't really
present any obvious traffic difficulties
that I can judge that aren't common all
around the town and obviously you assume
that the person is a safe driver and
will reverse in and drive out and look
both ways I don't see that parking there
is really much different to when it was
a garage in truth okay thank you very
much proceed chairman can I ask one more
question I put it in the bar
I apologize if I've missed it because I
you know same as everybody else wait
where is the highways report from the
highways can I refer to that versus the
highways report it's not on my papers
chairman there isn't one sorry sorry
chairman I was looking at the
presentation and then I couldn't get
back to you sorry we call might have
been consulted on items versus matters
such as this highways we as members now
we've got our own adopted guidance
simulation two-car parking so highways
is in Essex don't comment on matters
such it's level of car parking etc for
Malden the only comment on impacts on
the free flow of highway traffic so
matters such as this they wouldn't
consult on this even goes which is a
personal frustration myself if for
example there was a public house with a
massive car park and they wanted to
build 20 houses on that carpark highways
would still say no objection even though
you know all the cars would now be on
the road so personally profession I have
a frustration with that but we are where
we are in that respect
and I've see it there comes down to
professional judgment of officers
immolation the car park obviously it's
too fronted one is I'll see the
difficulties of actually using the space
but also it is that there's an
additional bedroom so the car parking
requirements have gone up to
if members don't consider this is a an
issue whether that's because they
consider it to be a more sustainable
location or because they just think that
it isn't particularly inconvenience
that's within their judgment but that's
up for them to make that decision
Thank You chairman refusal we have
approval but the councillor step no
counselor Jamie do you want me to chest
conditions I would suggest it was the
standard three of time plans and
materials an additional one in relation
to the tree protection as recommended by
the conservation or not soy tree consult
a and and conditions in relation to car
parking and retain incidental use of the
car at lodge which would just be sort
the standard conditions we've put under
elements such as this okay Thank You
chairman
so we're voting to approve contrary to
the officers recommendation please state
clearly four against or abstain when I
call your name councillor Basinger for
Thank You councillor Bell for Kostich
Anna well chairman I did state earlier
that I would not be voting okay thank
you
come stein castor Hall for the skenes
for as the stamp for burner please thank
you so that's five for the application
none against and two abstentions
right that's Julie approved any other
Isis of business at the chairman of the
committee decides our urgent there are
none and I will now close the meeting
that's whatever time it is
14:54